hi this is presh talwalkar in this video
i'm going to teach you the lattice
method of multiplication
let's say you wanted to multiply 12 by
13. we'll draw out a 2x2 table and we'll
write the number 12 in the row and the
number 13 in the column
now we'll multiply the number in the
column by the number in the row so one
times one is one
two times one is two
one times three is three
and two times three is six
now we add up the numbers diagonally so
this becomes first diagonal is six then
two plus three is five and our final
diagonal is just one
and that's our answer of a hundred and
fifty-six
let's do another example of 15 times 21
we'll draw at our table but this time
we'll actually draw in diagonals so
it'll be easier to add up the numbers
when we multiply the numbers we want to
write it as a two-digit number so one
times two is zero two two times five is
ten
one times one is zero one and five times
one is zero five
now we add up the numbers diagonally so
the first diagonal is five the next is
one
the next is two plus one is three and
the final diagonal is zero so this is
zero three one five which we just write
as three hundred fifteen
let's do an example of three digit
numbers we need to draw out a three by
three table because each of the numbers
has three digits
we write the number 526 in the row and
321 in the column
now we multiply each number
in each column by the number of that
particular row
the great part about lattice
multiplication is you only have to know
how to multiply simple things
your times table up to nine
because that's how you can solve for
each box
now we'll add up the numbers
diagonally and finally we make one
adjustment this 18 we need to carry over
the one
so 7 plus 1 is 8 and that gets us to our
answer
we can also use lattice multiplication
for polynomials when we do x plus two
times x plus three we write x plus two
in the row and x plus three in the
column
x times x is an x squared two times x is
two x
x times three is three x and two times
three is six we add everything together
grouping together the x terms and we
have x squared plus five x plus six
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel
you can support me on patreon to get
rewards catch me on my blog binder
decisions on twitter at preshtalwalkar
and you can get my books at amazon